it's nothing more than smoke and mirrors
we must be talking America's debt and
deficit politicians of all persuasions
they continue to cut level they maintain
this arcane thing non-defense
discretionary spending and avoided all
cars tough defense and non-defense
non-discretionary items stay with us
Peter Orszag olds to count them two
degrees from the London School of
Economics and smoke and mirrors he's a
former director of the CBO guys like a
grazer and smoke and mirrors yeah
degrees in smoke and mirrors but but
Peter guys like you should be taking a
massive victory lap our deficit is two
point nine percent of GDP did you do it
or did a better economy to it it's a
combination of things I and little-known
fact that long-term projected debt has
come down substantially if you look at
the number for 20-40 which is hugely
uncertain it's been cut in half since
2010 that did you because you trust that
data only earned you but the point is
everyone out there saying we were on a
completely unsustainable course the
revision since over the past five years
have been very positive partly due to
the economy but that was not unexpected
what was what was unexpected was the
massive slowdown in Medicare and
Medicaid costs that in particular is a
big driver of the improvement in our
long-term deficit Bloomberg Businessweek
were an article last week that pointed
out that all the budget resolutions both
thinking to the ones coming from the
house and the Senate but also you know
coming from think tanks as well they all
agree no matter what don't touch Social
Security is that fight over for now for
now it's over I mean I think we should
be putting our emphasis on continuing
this deceleration in health care
spending there is a little bit of
evidence that Medicare spending started
to tick up a little bit we need to kind
of knock it back down before it that
trend reverses that would be the most
important thing we could do oh the
experiments in the Affordable Care Act
on how to do this how to bring down
medical spending which is the one that
has borne the most fruit it looks like
the come it's a combination of things
the combination of digitizing the system
which actually was part of the stimulus
not the Affordable Care Act yeah and
then changing the way the doctors and
hospitals are paid moving towards fee
for value seems to be working we're
getting rid
and readmission rates we're getting
reductions in hospital acquired
infection rates if you create a
financial incentive for doctors and
hospitals yeah to produce better value
care they will write I had the memory of
a moment of Alan Greenspan lecturing
phil gramm and our surplus could not be
good for the country is there an
appropriate deficit does peter orszag
have in his head like two percent
inflation for the fed is there a
one-percent deficit to gdp or 39 there's
not an optimal deficit what we want your
friend chiloquin what we wanted i mean
there is your eerie but in practice what
we want to avoid is an unsustainable
course where the debt is exploding as a
share of the economy and if you look at
the current projection we succeeded we
for now but it is amazing to think back
to what tom is talking about in 2001
when Alan Greenspan gave testimony to
the house and he said you know do please
don't let me don't let me have a surplus
what an amazing you know that just shows
how uncertain these projections are why
caution is warranted and we should be
doubling what are you gonna listen for
any election campaign Republicans and
Democrats you've worked for a Democrat
president but I'm gonna call you
relatively unbiased what will you listen
for from candidates your world of fiscal
the most important thing is actually um
how you could possibly get any important
legislation through a congress that will
likely be divided that is the core
policy challenge of our time so the
specifics i'll be listening for but if
you just go out with a proposal that
appeals to one side or the other and has
no hope of getting through a spring
Congress then it's all just rhetoric we
can't get things through that everybody
agrees on everybody says that we should
reform the corporate tax code everybody
does but but there's no agreement on
what that so yes at this level reform
the corporate tax be a problem with that
as an example is everyone wants someone
else's tax cuts to be curled back in
order to provide an overall tax break
well I'm fascinated there are two things
one is infrastructure spending the other
is reforming the corporate tax code
where even between the White House and
Congress there's the framework of a
broad agreement agreement on the on the
bumper sticker version it's the detail
so how do you do it what kind of
infrastructure spending what corporate
tax reform are you moving towards a
territorial system or are you moving
away from a territorial system
both say corporate tax reform but they
mean many different things puter Idzik
how do you respond to people that say we
don't need another aircraft carrier
we've got to stop this bomber or that
give us an update on defense spending
not non-defense discretionary but actual
defense spending what's your to-do list
their defense spending there are two key
things that have to happen there one is
we need to sort out and we haven't fully
done it what happens to what's called
end strength that is the number of
troops we actually have the actual body
to body count that is a huge driver
that's a driver of basically two-thirds
of the defense budget we are moving and
just you look to look no further than
the islands disputes with China that
where the rhetoric is heating up there
are lots of threats out there in the
world we are on a path where we're going
to have to under these discretionary
caps significantly curtailed the number
of troops that we have I think a big
debate will be whether they're
conceivable or not the second is what
kind of investments are we making moving
into unmanned aircraft and even unmanned
naval ships for example or ships that
can handle unmanned aircraft that is a
big transformation that has to happen we
need to make sure we're not buying
equipment that worked 15 years ago
instead of fighting the future war